figureau live bonsoir on est en direct
ce lundi
de l'émission de tf1 la france face à la
guerre a rendez vous avec huit des douze
candidats à la présidentielle alors ce
n'était pas vraiment un débat on va en
parler avec mon invité du jour arnaud
benedetti politologue rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et de la revue
parlementaire bonjour arnaud enfin bon
soir plutôt au
nom de débriefer bien sur ce qui s'est
passé lors de cette émission vous
n'hésitez pas dans les commentaires à
poser vos questions à nous dire ce que
vous avez pensé de ce débat si vous
intéresser on essaiera d'y répondre le
bo mieux possible arnaud on peut
commencer par une par une question un
peu général qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir
de ce de ce débat qui n'en était pas
vraiment à au final
c'était une confrontation sans
véritablement
affrontements le premier enseignement on
revenir c'est le format et on m'a une
certaine manière nouveau sur le plan est
bien de la confrontation politique à la
télévision une sorte d'entre deux entre
eux à la fois le débat qui n'en était
pas un comme vous l'avait dit et
l'intervention de candidats répondant
aux questions de journalistes
sur une scène en forme de rim d'une
certaine manière mais de ring encore une
fois sans véritable combat donc premier
premier enseignement le froid qu à vous
il néanmoins pose question parce que on
peut pas dire véritablement que il a su
est vraisembablement disons
soutenir l'attention de tous les
téléspectateurs en phase 1b tendre et
devant les deux heures et demie
d'émission deuxième sucre deuxième
deuxième enseignement c'est que
finalement on a eu des candidats qui eux
en tout cas pour ceux qui auraient des
monnaies puisqu'elle avait 4 qui eux ne
participait pas à cette émission qui
sont quand même restés tout son temps
les uns que les autres que dans leur war
donc on a assisté à une forme de
neutralisation à distance de l'ensemble
de ses candidats troisième enseignement
après on a eu si vous voulez vous allez
dire des sur le plan formelle des
différences entre les candidats qui pour
certains lorsqu'ils se sont retrouvés
face aux journalistes
sont restés debout et ont pas mal bougé
pour la scène c'est le cas notamment de
valérie pécresse ou d'anne hidalgo
d'autres qui ont fait le choix de
s'asseoir comme s'ils étaient plus à
l'aise en étant dans une position
leur permettait vaisseau moment de
pouvoir peut-être mieux s'exprimer donc
voilà à peu près ce que l'on peut
retenir après sur le contenu les uns et
les autres sans surprise ont déroulé
finalement leur analyse de la situation
et puis ensuite les principales
propositions par rapport aux questions
qui leur étaient posées par les
journalistes alors évidemment évidemment
il y avait quand même un élément qui
peut être changé la donne c'est que
malgré tout c'est la première fois que
nous avions un président de la
république
même s'il s'agissait pas d'un débat
accepté de participer à une émission à
armes égales dans un exercice
équivalent de l'ensemble de ses
concurrents donc ça c'était une petite
nouveauté mais avec on voit bien quand
même un avantage qui était donné à
emmanuel macron notamment sur les
questions relatives à l'actualité de la
guerre tout simplement parce qu'il est
en situation enfin un avantage relatif
en l'occurrence mais qui faisait que on
l'a on avait à la fois le candidat et
président oui on a eu ces thèmes et
c'était vraiment quelque chose de
spécial on a l'impression qu'il y avait
au milieu de cette petite alors c'est un
peu normal aussi mais au milieu de cette
grande interview de candidats une
interview présidentielle en plein milieu
finalement
oui alors forcément mais si vous voulez
c'est et j'allais dire c'était
inévitable parce que le regard que nous
autres
téléspectateur citoyen observateurs aux
monteurs
pourtant eu sur emmanuel macron à la
télévision il est construit tout
simplement par l'image et le stade
présidentielle d'emmanuel macro ont donc
inévitablement j'allais dire presque
mais gâtés mécaniquement nous regardions
ce candidat comme s'il était aussi et il
était le président de la république qui
plus est dans une situation est dans un
contexte où la présidentialisation est
encore plus forte ou la présidentialité
du candidat est encore plus forte fin du
candidat-président est encore plus fort
parce que nous sommes dans une situation
de très grande tension géopolitique et
d'ailleurs je rappelle quand même le
titre de l'émission c'était face à la
guerre on voyait bien que il y avait
aussi la volonté de la part de la
production de tf2 d'une certaine manière
de faire entrer toute la dramaturgie du
contexte dans ce moment qui est aussi un
moment de compétition électorale alors
on a flight 92 sur une table dans les
commentaires du figaro qui dit je trouve
que le candidat le plus sincère et eric
zemmour macron était le plus plat
pécresse la plus fausse après chacun
trouvera son poulain le meilleur par
esprit partisan ou par rapport à sa
sensibilité j'ai l'impression que c'est
beaucoup ça dans les commentaires en
tout cas de qu'on reçoit tout le monde
soutient on a beaucoup de zemmour
mélenchon pécresse macron dans nos
commentaires tout le monde soutient un
peu son plan est ce que pour autant on
peut dire qu'il ya des candidats qui ont
mieux réussi l'exercice que d'autres
c'est toujours très difficile lorsqu en
plus si vous voulez contrairement à un
débat en nous avons deux candidats qu'on
ne l'était pas
l'entre-deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle où là il ya une
confrontation se fait azif entre deux
tempéraments de caractère de trajectoire
de vol du ticket ou éventuellement on
peut à un moment donné même si on essaye
disons de 2,2 de
contenir sa subjectivité
peut-être trouvé qu'un candidat semble
prendre le dessus sur l'autre par une
formule par une punchline et en
l'occurrence c'est pas le cas c'est
extrêmement difficile ce qui fait que
finalement comme c'est souvent le cas
dans une red deer dans un format
de confrontation politique de ce type
chacun en fonction de ça semblait dite
de sa sensibilité de ses opinions que
ses convictions de ses valeurs pas
trouvé d'une certaine manière midi à sa
porte au regard du candidat gaza donc
c'est très difficile à ce stade de
considérer qu' il ya un candidat qui
aurait fait la différence dans cette
émission par rapport à d'autres
candidats on peut éventuellement jugé si
vous voulez la forme certains sont
apparus parfois un peu plus emprunter
que d'autres d'aucuns sont apparus
peut-être on écrit un peu plus spontané
que d'autres d'autres un peu plus
triebel que d'autres mais sur le fond
essayez de considérer qu' il y a eu un
candidat qui l'emporterait par exemple
ce soir ça me paraît un exercice très
compliqué et très difficile mais parce
que comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
chacun est un peu dans sa ligne lors de
cet exercice et au final vu qu'il n'y a
pas d'opposition frontale avec d'autres
candidats finalement c'est des choses
qu'on savait déjà sur les sur ses
candidats
on n'a strictement rien à plis sûr je
pense le programme des candidats sur le
diagnostic ils peuvent faire chacun à
leur niveau de la
situation ou encore une fois
et véritablement les différencier c'est
d'être en effet le degré de spontanéité
la maîtrise un moment donné d'une
gestuelle
ou d'un comportement mais sur le fond
c'est j'allais dire une émission qui est
d'une certaine manière sans surprise
hormis en effet encore une fois ce
format un peu un peu nouveau en tout cas
qui fait qu' on est à la fois dans un
débat qui se fait en parallèle mais qui
n'est pas un véritable débat une espèce
d'entre deux en fait qui est le produit
d'une circonstance c'est à dire que pour
la première fois un président de la
république sur thor est
confronté avec eux la nécessité un
moment donné de sortir du surplomb qui
est le sien pour eux se confronter alors
avec en effet un format encore une fois
très très très très singulier à ses
autres concurrents voiture enfin il faut
rappeler qu'effectivement à
mâcon ne veut pas débattre directement
avec les autres et du coup peut-être
juste je vous permets mais il a quand
même malgré tout et ses petites salles
peut-être le plus important ce soir
c'est que il a enclenché
malgré tout et malgré lui peut-être
aussi sous la pression médiatique je
sais que ces fonds on bat bhl un
processus où finalement maintenant un
sortant ne pourra plus tout à fait
rester dans la position de surplomb qui
était la sienne avant finalement ce que
l'on a vécu ce soir s'il ya un petit
événement ce soir quand même c'est que
il y a quelque chose du point de vue de
la communication politique qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui un président de la
république y compris quand il est sorti
et compris quand il est à nouveau
candidat est obligé de se prêter à un
exercice de ce type quand bien même cet
exercice ne serait pas tout à fait un
débat mais on a un vrai savoir
enclencher quelque chose de nouveau ce
soir c'est peut-être la seule nouveauté
mais ça c'est un petit pas qui a été
donnée qui pourra dans les futures
élections qui soient remarqués en tout
cas dans les futures élections si on se
retrouve dans un cadre de président qui
essaie d'être réélu
oui en effet cassé c'est l'un des
enseignements qu'on peut qu'on peut
tirer de cette de cet exercice
ce soir bon mais encore une fois on est
très loin d'une confrontation c'est
chacun de ces candidats qui a pu
dérouler sous le feu des questions des
journalistes sont son programme c'était
l'objectif après dire est ce que cet
exercice va avoir un impact à la fois
sur les intentions de vente ou sur
l'intérêt même eu les françaises et les
français vont manifester ou cette
campagne je ne suis pas sûr que
l'exercice de ce soir au change
fondamentalement la donne il en était là
quand même
après une séquence qui a été eu quand
même complètement cannibaliser et à
juste titre d'ailleurs la raison parce
que l'on a vécu en ukraine est ce que
l'on continue à vivre en ukraine et
d'une certaine manière la campagne
revient un peu au centre en tout cas
cela la vie politico médiatique elle en
était un peu sortis encore une fois à
cause des événements tragiques que l'on
connaît en ukraine maintenant depuis
quinze jours est ce qu'une émission
comme ça peut lancer finalement cette
campagne qui comme verdi a du mal à
démarrer
mais la campagne a été lancée déjà un
pompe au fait si vous voulez réclame
quand on regarde la campagne on parle de
cette campagne présidentielle de
maintenant plusieurs mois en fait depuis
le mois de septembre on a eu différentes
séquences dans cette campagne et des
salles c'est un feuilleton la campagne
on l'a vu la séquence eric zemmour va
t'il être candidat ne va-t-il pas l'être
la dynamique zemmour qui a précédé sa
déclaration de candidature ensuite on a
eu
on lie également la primaire des verts
on a eu ensuite le congrès qui a désigné
à partir d'une compétition interne de
valérie pécresse on a eu tous les
événements liés à l'évolution des
attentions vente en live ensuite quand
même la déclaration de candidature dans
un contexte tout à fait particulier
des manuels maquereau en dehors dire
qu'il n'y a pas de campagne je crois que
c'est quand même un jugement qui me
paraît un peu un peu excessif il y à une
campagne bon après la difficulté
fondamentale c'est que peut-être que
cette campagne aujourd'hui n'intéresse
pas les français comme les campagnes
passées pouvait intéresser des français
mais il ya quelque chose de
fondamentalement nouveau qu'il faut
vraiment avoir en tête c'est que les
campagnes que l'on vit aujourd'hui sont
des campagnes beaucoup plus longues que
par le passé les campagnes commence
beaucoup pour il ne faut jamais
l'oublier en 2017 la campagne avait
commencé avant l'été 2016 avec la
préparation de la primaire notamment des
républicains là cette fois ci de la même
manière on a une campagne qui a commencé
très tour s'est liée notamment à
l'accélération du temps médiatique c'est
lié aussi à l'accélération du calendrier
institutionnel on est sur un quinquennat
aujourd'hui donc la campagne est très
forte et en fait la réalité c'est que on
est quasiment en campagne dès le
lendemain de l'élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui donc ça change
considérablement le contexte le mal
c'est qu'il faut réussir à à soutenir
l'attention ed des électrices et des
électeurs sur un ton beaucoup l'on ne
pourrait pas que par le passé ce qui
fait que parfois on a des changements de
rythme comme dans une course cycliste
des bains qui fait que l'on peu de temps
à autre avoir la perception d'une
campagne qui n'existerait pas et
pourtant sur le front et il existe c'est
c'est bien plus une course de fond
maintenant une campagne présidentielle
par rapport à avancer sa gouaille à dire
ah oui clairement mc laren c'est à dire
qu'en fait le temps de la campagne le
temps médiatique aussi de la campagne de
la précampagne et beaucoup l'ont eu par
le passé quand une fois c'est lié au
fait que nous ne vivons plus du tout
dans le même écosystème médiatique celui
que l'on connaissait en 1965 que celui
que l'on connaisse en 1974 que celui que
l'on connaissait en 1981 et même je
dirais que celui que nous connaissions
en 1995 ou avant 2002 il y à une
accélération il fait que
vraisemblablement les conditions
d'exercice du combat politique ont
considérablement changé fayet ya le fait
que nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un
rythme qui est un rythme de quinquennat
et le quinquennat changent malgré tout
la natte fonctionnement des institutions
ça a été dit et rappelé par eux de
nombreux constitutionnalistes je vais
prendre quelques quelques commentaires
chantal meyer qui disent et maquereau
qui a refusé de débattre c'est lui le
seul fautif incapable de défendre son
quinquennat fait 92 davantage cet
exercice et que les candidats ont pu
développer leurs programmes calmement et
sans invective un débat apaisé donc pas
vraiment un débat une fois de plus mais
peut-être que ça permet aussi aux
français qui ne s'était pas assez peu
être intéressées à la campagne d'avoir
une bonne vision sur un instant t avec
tous les candidats de leur programme
assez précisément
oui alors c'est vrai là je vous joins à
ce que dit votre intérieur c'est en
effet un format de ce type ça évite
d'une certaine manière la foire dont
poigne que l'on a pu connaître dans les
débats petit il y avait qui a 5 ans
avaient scandé le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle voir les face
à face comme le face à face au mcs connu
la semaine dernière entre eux
particulièrement
particulièrement difficile parfois entre
madame pécresse et monsieur zemmour
parce que là en effet ils sont dans une
situation qui est assez confortable pour
tout simplement décliné
leur offre politique pour décliner leurs
propositions sans être interrompu à
l'exception bien évidemment des
questions et des interrogations que
peuvent leur poser les deux les deux
journalistes donc oui le format se
prêtent beaucoup plus disons au
caractère didactique pédagogique des
passionnés eux face à face ou là on est
fait vous avez un affrontement direct
entre différents candidats qui sont là
pour aller se chercher ou éventuellement
se piéger ou rêvée pour se contredire
évidemment eu pour à la limite faire
perdre la face à leurs concurrents on
est disons dans un exercice qui est
beaucoup moins eux or tiff et qui est
beaucoup plus pédagogiques ce que l'on
gagne en effet on pédagogie par son côté
très didactique vert on le perd quand
même en compte
j'allais oublier que quand même dans une
démocratie il y à des joutes il y à des
joutes et des affrontements ça fait
partie aussi de la loi du genre oui là
le seul
commentaire levier sur lequel pouvait se
jouer aussi les candidats c'est le
public on a justement charles martel qui
me dit j'ai bien aimé la façon qu'elle
disait jadot pour convaincre les jeunes
à aller voter donc je pense que c'est
beaucoup d'amants il s'adressait au
public ils n'ont pas tous fait non plus
de se se
d'arriver à parler à ce public plutôt
que de parler aux journalistes aux
téléspectateurs
oui alors qu'ils ont fait des choix
différents les uns les autres on a vu
certains qui étaient beaucoup plus
tournée vers la relation avec les
journalistes c'est à dire ça sur les
journalistes comme des intermédiaires
qui leur permettront de développer et
d'appuyer leurs messages d'autres qui
ont tant bien évidemment répondant aux
journalistes donné parfois le sentiment
ou la volonté de vouloir ils ont
contourné les journalistes pour
s'adresser directement au public bon ce
sont des j'allais dire des techniques
d'opérationnalité et vettori qui sont
assez acide science est important c'est
que on voit bien que aujourd'hui ce qui
change considérablement peut-être la
communication politique avec ce type de
format c'est que on a dix ont un degré
d'improvisation
ce qui est beaucoup moindre que par le
passé comme si nous étions finalement
vous savez ça me faisait penser à cette
émission se vend il c'est à dire des
candidats qui sont là pour essayer de
faire la démonstration devant un jury
qui sont porteurs d'un message d'un
talent hors d'elle savoir faire du neuf
une maîtrise comme si on avait aussi
affaire à des comédiens d'une certaine
manière au delà de 2 des femmes et des
hommes des femmes et des hommes
politiques
c'est aussi ça que l'on peut retenir de
ce type de prestation
après l'impact que ça peut avoir ça ça
reste vraiment au rami s'est réuni oui
parce que c est ce qu est ce que
justement ces grandes émissions de débat
alors celle là c'est un peu une première
du georges on peut on peut le dire avec
un ancien candidat est ce que les débats
en général ça une vraie importance avant
le vote
ça dépend de quel type de débat on parle
ici où on si on se réfère à l'histoire
des débats des grands débats télévisés
de l'entre-deux tours d'une élection
présidentielle
le premier débat c'est 1974 valéry
giscard d'estaing et françois mitterrand
ce que ce que lisent les politiciens des
politologues en règle générale de ce
type de débat c'est que ces débats ne
renforce les convictions de partisans de
chaque camp et ne font vraisemblablement
pas la différence politique e on
souhaiterait e e on souhaiterait on
souhaiterait voir la réalité c'est que
bonds sont 14 on doit considérer par
exemple que valéry giscard d'estaing
avait déplacé un certain nombre de voix
à partir d'une can fly zepa punch à
l'époque va partir d'une formule où il
avait vous savez dit à françois
mitterrand que il n'avait pas le
monopole du coeur en 1981 euros
retournement de situation on a un
françois mitterrand dieu fasse ça
il ya eu finalement présente françois
mitterrand qu'on va le nombre passer
françois mitterrand lui au lui renvoie
une longue du passif donc bon est ce que
ces formules un moment donné ou un
impact suffisant ont déplacé des voix
nul ne peut le dire ce qui est sûr c'est
que par contre elle s'oriente
vraisemblablement les commentaires des
commentateurs sont là pour décrypter
finalement le le débat c'est à dire que
ç'a un impact sur les interprètes du
débat qui pourrait être des uns et des
autres à différents niveaux parce que
nous allons considérer que intel a été
plus performant un moment donné que eux
que sont que son que son concurrent
certes on voit bien que le débat raté
considéré en tout cas comme ratée de
marine le pen en 2017 à
des vrais seins moment peut-être en voix
à marine le pen mais sur
lala profondément handicapée pendant de
nombreuses années peut pour simplement
être considéré et encore aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs être considérée comme une
candidat qui serait crédible et
incapacité est occupé la fonction
présidentielle comme si finalement le
niveau de compétence qui était le sien
avait été considéré comme insuffisant
invalidant pour in fine et e postuler à
la fonction de chef de l'état et ont
d'ailleurs on constate depuis maintenant
certain nombre d'années il des plus
selon moi et je fais tout pour essayer
de finalement faire oublier cette
prestation ratée c'est un hors-jeu pour
l interview à la fois images et e
on a failli qui nous dit le format
permettant de faire émerger de nouvelles
idées seraient un débat entre un
candidat une personne issue de la
société civile c'est ce qui se fait
alors pas en période de campagne
électorale mais on sait ce qu'on a vu
par exemple sur france 2 ou sur lci les
des émissions face au français
finalement mais c'est plus vraiment
d'aider des débats présidentiels en tout
cas
là je vais oui là la réalité c'est que
les formats aujourd'hui on a on a
beaucoup de formats
et dire d'exposition du politique par
rapport aux électrices et aux électeurs
autant de formats et qu'il existe est ce
de médias et d'autres de l'offre offre
médiatique la vérité c'est que
la difficulté aujourd'hui
principal pour tous les candidats quel
qu'il soit c'est de faire en sorte que
la politique soit à nouveau attractive
c'est à dire que la politique soit de
nouveau en mesure
de fabriquer et de citoyens on voit bien
que malheureusement une grande partie
aujourd'hui des offres politiques la
plupart des offres et que se heurte à la
fois un phénomène d'indifférence de
désintérêt de mécontentement parfois de
colère qui
nourrissent ce que l'on appelle la crise
de la représentation qui se manifeste
notamment par des taux d'abstention qui
sont des taux d'abstention très
important qu'on l'a vu lors des
élections municipales ou des élections
régionales ou même lors des élections
législatives de 2007 et aujourd'hui ils
ailleurs en inde et que dire des angles
morts de cette campagne c'est l'essence
savoir quel sera le niveau de
participation parce que le niveau de
participation sera un paramètre à fait
décisif pour en savoir un peu plus sur
le rapport de force au delà des seuls
sondages en fonction de ce niveau de
participation et en évidemment un
certain nombre de candidats pourront
peut être eu disons avoir un rapport de
forces plus favorable que si le niveau
de participation est faible donc là il
ya un vrai sujet et qui interpelle
l'ensemble de la classe politique à ce
que nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un
processus est un processus quelles que
soient les émissions de télévision
quelles que soient les formats de
communication dans un processus de
désaffiliation politique il lui est un
vrai sujet un sujet particulièrement
graves et parfois même inquiétant oui
parce que cette participation alors
l'élection présidentielle est un peu
sauvé en général avec un fort taux de
participation alors qu'en général depuis
de nombreuses années la participation à
toutes les élections s'écroule de plus
en plus
oui alors il ya une tendance maintenant
sur près d'une trentaine d'années
d'affaiblissement de la passion toutes
élections confondues
y compris d'ailleurs l'élection
présidentielle malgré tout subi
elle-même certes plus faible érosion
mais aussi une petite érosion
en cette matière je crois que l'un des
enjeux en effet un des grands enjeux de
cette élection
2022 sera la question de la
participation
aujourd'hui on regarde par exemple
niveau de certitude de choix
des électeurs en fonction des
différentes offres piqué que cette
certitude de choix
comparativement à d'autres élections
présidentielles quel que soit d'ailleurs
les candidats est faible elle ne l'était
ça veut dire que finalement l'opinion
publique non seulement est moins
intéressé mais elle est aussi faite ce
faible intérêt à cet intérêt moindre que
par le passé elle est aussi beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus volatile
effectivement alors fait 92 qui continue
avec son idée de deux débatteurs ebe en
fait il parlait dans ma super débatteurs
sélectionnés par la chaîne passionné de
politique avec de solides compétences en
la matière c'est un peu compliqué à
trouver dans la sphère publique et dans
ce pas compliqué mais après ils seraient
affiliés au système finalement donc ce
serait plus vraiment de la société
civile on va dire
il s'appelle un journaliste est en règle
générale away d'analystes
dire c'est si bien là existent déjà sur
le marché médiatique le marché de
l'analyse politique et qu'
il n'y a pas de si vous les deux de
formule 2 formule miracle
et si vous voulez le vrai problème
aujourd'hui delà de la politique c'est
pas tant un problème de communication
comme d'ailleurs où souvent les ongles
des femmes politiques je pense plutôt
qu'un problème de contenu politique
d'offre politique de restauration d'un
lien démocratique entre la société et le
politique entre la société et le wa il
n'y a pas un rouge c'est de la folie il
y à un roger vraisemblablement 2e de la
classe politique ça c'est une réalité on
peut le regretter mais c'est une vérité
quand on regarde par exemple l'ensemble
des études aujourd'hui qui mesure la
confiance des français
dans leurs dirigeants politiques la
france est un des pays où le projet de
la classe politique et le fort il ya de
ce point de vue là une exception même
française eux que l'on voit notamment à
travers encore une fois les niveaux
d'abstention et le jugement très sévère
qui est porté sur la classe politique de
la part de nos compatriotes et la
communication politique de ce point de
vue là eu ni peu très peu en
l'occurrence ce qui pose problème
surtout dans un pays comme la france qui
est un pays extrêmement politique
historiquement assez le rappelle souvent
mais c'est l'état qui est la nation
c'est l'état qui fait devenir la société
où le relatons beaucoup de l'état dans
un pays où l'état à paris en tout cas un
acteur moins puissant qu'il ne le fut
par le passé il ya des phénomènes
déceptif qui explique aujourd'hui aussi
à la fois la différence
là à dire le retrait civique et la
colère critique donc les allées limite
j'allais bien des questions de
communication sont presque périphériques
par rapport à des problèmes aussi lourds
que ceux auxquels nous sommes confrontés
effectivement merci beaucoup arnaud mine
ity d'avoir été avec nous ce soir pour
débriefer ce grand débat l'article sur
le figaro que vous invite à lire
maintenant c'est celui qu on est en
train de vous montrer à l'écran pris
dans celles de 20 de ce qu'il faut
retenir du premier grand oral télévisé
des principaux candidats puisqu'il faut
le rappeler ce n'était pas un vrai débat
chacun est aidé en scène comme on l'a
dit avec avec un no mercy une fois de
plus d'avoir été avec nous merci aux
internautes aussi d'avoir été nombreux à
avoir commenté n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner pour ceux qui nous ont suivis
sur youtube et moi je vous dis à bientôt
pour de nouveaux lives sur figaro live